we're coming down the home stretch when
we thought about who would be the right
person to kind of wrap our day up for us
Lorcan dempseys name came you know right
to the top of our minds and plus he he
owed me one uh he and I had recently
worked on earth on it on a on an issue
of portal and we had been in
conversation so we were able to reach
out to him and talk but but uh organ is
vice president and chief strategist of
OCLC research his many influential
contributions to the professional
literature are widely recognized as is
his long-running blog which was recently
edited into a book entitled the network
reshapes the library he's the only
person i know whose blog has been made
into a book he has received the national
federation of advanced information
services highest honor the miles conrad
award and has twice received the all
sits Presidential Citation Lord Lorcan
is one of our professions big thinkers
and we cannot think of a better person
to offer his thoughts and a wrap-up of
our day welcome working all right thank
you for that it's definitely downhill
from there a reflective discussion what
I've done is I've got some observations
about the particular areas I did try and
weave in this morning some of the
comments that were made through some of
the sessions but then I had to load the
presentation at lunchtime so I I
couldn't do anything after that a couple
of pre ludes first one about Jim Jim
himself he didn't tell that story today
thankfully um III did think I ought to
mention coming from OCLC Jim is now a
member of our board and very strong
advocate for for libraries and for
research libraries in that context and
because Jim is on our board I am wearing
my interview suit today and the second
the second point that I wanted to make
is I don't think Jim gets enough credit
frankly that's a bit of a weasel word
isn't it frankly I don't think Jim gets
enough credit for how much he has done
for us all at considerable personal cost
and you know quite quite a bit of an
embarrassment I think that but he really
has raised the bar at for a bad library
humor
hey it really has given the rest of us
the freedom to tell terrible jokes at
conferences so I won't mention the pig
with the wooden leg um I right well it'd
be more like you won't tell it for a
price how much would it cost to keep you
quiet the i can speak without power and
can speak without point but i usually do
speak with power points so i will i'll
continue with the power point i was
interested in in the title of the
earlier remarks relationship between
power point in excel is that you dream
and powerpoint and you have nightmares
in excel okay so pre lewd number two I
did I do think it might be worth
beginning by saying a few things about
some some general trends in in libraries
we heard earlier about big shift you
know we have long revolutions whatever
so there is a sir major rebalancing long
term underway and I thought might be
worthwhile saying a few things about
some ways of characterizing that one way
of characterizing it is historically we
tend to think about the user in the life
of the library so we think about the
library we think about collections we
think about services we think about
building and we think about how the user
comes to those uses those as helped
using those very much in the last few
years we have to think about the library
in the life of the user we have to start
with research work flows with learning
needs we have to start with at the user
wherever the user is and then think
about how to relate the library to those
needs the discussion about digitization
and Greg crowns discussion about
digitization very much how do we get
these things into the hands of users
later discussion about at research or
workflows what to research how do we get
the library into the life of the user
rather than imagine building the library
and
the user come into to the library and I
think this is lots of implications some
joking about libraries desire for
control librarians desire for control
historically libraries were sort of
bureaucratic organizations in the sense
if you think about what if your
bureaucracy is bureaucracy is something
that has reasonably well known goals and
a lot of your effort goes into
reproducing the means or reorganizing
the means towards those goals so what
libraries did was we want very good
technical services we want very good
public services we want and we work on
the means we improve the means because
the library is relatively stable and we
understand the goals if you contrast
that with a an enterprise where an
enterprise is more entrepreneurial and
the goals change and you have to reshape
the means to meet those changing goals
and a lot of the discussion that we've
had today it seems to me relates to that
so what sorts of decisions do we now
make about space it was clear what space
was there for spaces where you put the
collections we organized our spaces
around collections and the helped
libraries interpret those collections
have access to those collections now
we're thinking about organizing space in
such a way reorganizing it around user
experiences making choices about space
in different ways and having to make
choices about space we're having to make
choices about services which services
them to offer choices about expertise
going back to the workforce discussion
what types of expertise are needed it's
no longer a given that you have a set of
expertise as you you need at this set of
expertise which are produced in a
professional school call to library
school what you have now is having to
make choices about a set of expertise
that are required to actually bring the
library into the life of the user in in
sensible or effective ways and that's a
big change in terms of thinking and
because it requires a going strategy
strategy are the bets that you make on
the future and you're having to make
bets on the future now you're not
following and agree
each path it's it's you're not you know
you're not refining something that's
already understood you're making bets
you're making choices about how to use
resources how to move resources round
have to change resources how to do
things in a different way the library
was very infrastructure oriented it was
a a building with collections in it with
systems and the work revolved around
buildings collections and and systems
and what has now happened is we really a
lot of that infrastructure is moving up
in the network you want to share that
infrastructure you want to share it what
groups of colleagues you want to
potentially use network services for
some types of things and we've seen a
lot of this moving up in the network as
we share infrastructure it's very
difficult though and a lot of the
discussion earlier was about at some of
the difficulty of that collective
collection is removing collections up
but really how do we do that and so
focus on infrastructure that
infrastructure is changing and but
really the attention is now shifting to
some extent away from that
infrastructure are thinking about how we
manage that infrastructure differently
because the priority is engagement it's
engagement with at new forms of learning
and research it's engagement with at the
institution it's engagement with and the
practices that are emerging on campuses
so that you can create new value and
that means that you potentially need to
have certain new specialist skills
certain new ways of engaging ways of
doing things so a shift from
infrastructure to engagement a
requirement to do infrastructure maybe
in different ways calling forth new
collaborative arrangements which are
difficult and calling forward new skills
new ways of interacting from an
engagement point of view then in terms
of collections one of the things in the
digital environment which is quite
interesting is that in the print
environment you gather collections and
you interpret them for users users come
in they interact with the collections
that go away they create stuff goes into
the publishing environment it comes back
so the interaction with that whole
scholarly lifecycle
the library is at certain points in a
digital environment the engagement with
that life cycle can be at multiple
points so you may want to as we as we've
discussed interact around data interact
around new workflows interact around
tools interact around copyright interact
around publishing decisions interact
around and gathering preprints interact
around promotion interact around
researcher reputation interact around a
much wider range am I making funny
noises here no just I'm getting this
sort of funny all right okay okay we'll
keep going keep going okay could
somebody repeat that last sentence back
to me okay interact you yeah so you got
that okay so it means though that the
library is very much more engaged where
they create the full creative range of
activity not not just with collecting
final materials final outputs but
engaged with a fuller creative cycle so
that really shifts quite quite quite a
bit of the focus and and you know we're
in the middle of all of these shifts and
and this obviously causes some tensions
so thinking about a variety of the
things that were discussed earlier not
in the same order workforce I was
listening to the BBC while ago and there
was this program on about architects and
there was an architect on bemoaning the
fact that there were fewer employment
opportunities for architects because
architecture companies were employing
all these other people and it just
struck me it was exactly like some of
the conversations were having about
libraries so the point that they made
was well the opportunity the employment
opportunity for architects is not as
great as it was because
hours as companies engage in the
projects they're looking at at one stage
architects would do most of the work
architects would be called upon to do
add the full array of things that the
company had to do to complete its input
into into an assignment but this
despondent architect was saying and now
the company had project managers who had
a sort of generic background not
necessarily great architectural
knowledge engineers had come in much
more and because of the nature of some
of the buildings that there were being
looked at actual builders quantity
surveyors others were coming in place
makers I don't know I don't know what
place makers are to be honest somebody
else might but apparently an
architecture firm something place makers
developers whole range whole range of
other people and if you think about the
library I mean we have sort of similar
thing and listening to at this morning's
discussion you know we do think project
managers developers programmers but then
also if you think about the range of
things that we talked about the library
doing you know publisher is data
scientists scholars marketing legal
policy issues big interest recently
Deanna mentioned in F nog raphy if nog
refers several libraries have
anthropologist on staff and if you think
about the shift that I mentioned earlier
this is sort of natural enough because
you're thinking about and reaching out
in different ways you're thinking about
appealing to communities in different
ways interacting with them in different
ways which calls forth a different set
of skills so it seems to me that the the
trend that we're seeing is is sort of a
a natural one which doesn't mean it's
easy to manage or easy to deal with but
it is a natural one and one that will
will continue in this type of
environment then you do have issues
about how to create and scale learning
or you have different people coming
together
one of the Irish piece for a crl
recently about I was asked to to drive
Arkansas in a particular in the 75th
anniversary volume new roles for the
road ahead with memorable title and new
roles for the road ahead but the I
rocher piece about consortium and it
seemed to me the consortia have been
remarkably long-lived now some of them
are subscale some of them not quite
purpose you're seeing some shifting some
new ones are coming up shared printers
collecting is creating a lot of new
activity one of the primary values cell
consortium one of the reasons they are
long-lived is that they allow libraries
to scale learning they are places where
people can consort can talk can pool
uncertainty can discuss what's happening
I can get outside of the confines of
their institution to scale learning but
the importance I think of scaling
learning of allowing and different
people coming together to understand the
the organization and so on is something
that clearly becomes more important in
this kind of type of context and curse
of knowledge is an economic concept i
came across recently which it now
explains everything to me and so
apparently the curse of knowledge is a
person's predisposition to imagine that
everybody else knows the same as they do
so you know i imagine that you know at
the same as i do so for a presenter for
a teacher for a sales person and this
sort of is an issue as they're doing
things it seems to me librarians suffer
especially from the curse of knowledge
because you know the the symptoms of
this or that you might talk in jargon
you might talk in a in a more abstract
way than somebody can understand and
that you talk in a way that doesn't
necessarily map onto on to what people
and are expecting one of the big issues
about having people from different
backgrounds from different contacts is
it's a sort of corrective and to to to
that issue
because you you begin to have to not
just explain yourself to your
constituency but to your colleagues and
and and this creates a better prepared
organization to interact but thinking
about the diversity of expertise in an
institution it seems to me it better
prepares it then to interact with the
broader institution I put in have I
emerged yet because you know I find it
quite amusing all the the emerging posts
you know half the half the adverts that
you see now have strategy or strategic
in the title and then quite a few have
emerging and you know I sort of have
this sense of you know butterfly or
something emerging even my caterpillar
you know so the emerging technology
librarian fluttering in that's this you
know have you emerged have you emerged
yet but the it sort of seems like it's
it's a casual ization of a particular
issue you know it's putting it over here
that's emerging technology and here's
all the boring stuff that's never going
to emerge over here and so I don't know
just thinking about skills it occurred
to me and and Kenny said one of the
phrases to use was the resilience of
what librarianship is is all about even
though I didn't quite fully necessarily
understand it in the way that she meant
it because of the cursing knowledge I am
I I did feel you know that this is this
is potentially you know quite important
that there is institutional professional
practices values so there are important
around the institution of librarianship
separate from then a set of skills that
will may have the changes and and again
especially if you are thinking about the
library as an enterprise you're thinking
about new forms of engagement you're
thinking about engaging with creation
activities this calls for word a range
of new skills and abilities but what is
it that's particular or a special about
that institutional professional value of
those those cores and I put this picture
up a couple of years ago I participated
in this
a symposium workshop at unc-chapel Hill
about the future of library schools I
schools and they took the relatively
modest days of 2050 and to to look out
to and but what I was struck with during
those discussions with really that the
enormous conflict that you had here
between on the one hand bootstrapping a
library school into this future and on
the other hand this conflict if you like
between the institutional issues around
a library and the desire to train people
at Facebook or Google or whoever would
employ and really really sort of a
challenge so in terms of thinking about
what it is that one wants to have taught
in in these schools or what 11 producers
I think that really you know a lot of
thinking their skills skills you know
happening that's changing but what is
the profession the institution that
whatever I thought the Executive MBA
example was interesting in in that
context I'm innovation funding
innovation for some reason I chose gray
as the color here I don't know whether
that's I don't know whether that's
indicative of anything so this is a
picture by a horas de jeu  Simcoe he's
consultant and I found it very striking
when I first saw it so he's talking
about what people normally call
innovation or whatever so you've got
novelty and that's new you know it's
just so the choice of gold as a color
for the iphone as the example he gives
then you have creations you know what's
valuable but you know it's it's it's
valuable then he has invention which he
says is unique but then right at the end
he has innovation so innovation has to
be all of the other things but it also
has to actually be useful and this is
something we should remember that we
talked a lot about innovation but how
much of it is useful so innovation is
useful and I think the example
he gives they're actually quite
interesting the iphone pricing model at
google's revenue model the forward
production system walmart store design
amazon's logistics if you think about
these things these aren't shiny penny
types of things they're not you know
wonderful gizmos their institutional
innovation their innovation around
process their innovation that really
changes the way something happens to
create new value to create new
connections there changes in the sort of
architecture of the organization changes
in the ways in which parts of an
organization relate to each other to to
do things there they're sort of
fundamental institutional innovations
night and I thought that was quite
interesting if we think about library
activity if we think about funded
library activity interesting to sort of
think about how many things actually
move out along out on out along those
circles move out along into the
genuinely system-wide useful and element
now before I came to work for OCLC I can
I can I'm young enough still to be able
to remember that the and I work for JYSK
in the in the UK an organization that
provides infrastructure services to
higher education however so I was
responsible for their informational
spend their informational activity data
centers nation wash'n ille site license
saying a range of national
infrastructure information issues
however however we also had a large R&D
investment large project based funding
activity so we funded you know we had
calls and we funded a lot of
project-based work in sort of digital
digital library related activity you
know the sort of thing that you're very
familiar with so the main thing about
this was it made me very popular that
was that was the one thing so the the
you no one understands the the personal
dynamic of these things you know you
have a lot of money for but the
interesting thing about it is how do
projects move along this how do projects
move along this you know from being you
or interesting or valuable to
actually being useful how do you connect
an institutional development and
institutional initiative with a
system-wide development or initiative
and it you know it's interesting to
consider you know what we've done
successfully there and what is remained
within within the institution and I do
think that's an area where where some
serious investigation would be would be
would be quite interesting now by chance
and I came across this video a while ago
so this is a sociologist here at
Columbia and he's talking about
innovation and quite quite an
interesting way and so he says the
received wisdom about innovation is that
arises from some recombination of
existing and novel resources that bring
about something new so that's part of
the story and but it's the least
interesting part so that's the stuff
that's sort of near the center you know
that's the new novel gold iPhone you
know I'm type stuff the real achievement
and I think this should this should be
the basis of the basic goal of the
Academy is figuring out how to mobilize
new ideas so that they stabilize new
knowledge within larger networks of
interaction outside the Academy so the
example he uses is that pastor you know
so pastor works on pasteurization in in
the laboratory and it's by interacting
with these networks of physicians
farmers of others that he actually
stabilizes the idea of pasteurization
and moves it into general practice so
the argument is that you have to develop
solutions to problems but then you make
them stick by connecting them to larger
networks by connecting them to networks
of interaction by connecting them to
networks of different players who are
working together to solve your problems
who is the most successful person in the
digital library space Herbert banta
sample so Herbert is an inveterate
networker he he works very hard he did
specific library stuff doesn't really
work so now he does webby stuff he
interacts with
Webbie community he tries to stabilize
what he does in interaction networks of
scientists of the web community of other
people linked data mentioned earlier the
link data work that's being done is
trying to be stabilized by interacting
with google by doing a variety of other
things you have to move things up and
out into the networks that are important
to sustain and to carry a forward and I
think this is actually something quite
difficult for individual institutions to
do if you think about libraries again
and how do we create then systemic
change how do we move things into these
bigger networks and out of just the the
institution how do we create
institutional innovation that means that
we change the way things work so going
back to the discussion earlier and maybe
it was Jim that said you want to see
real strategy in action follow the
budget okay you want to see Oh sharing
stuff is very important how much money
gets moved into shared environments and
out of individual environments what we
have now is we have you know somebody
maybe Diana mentioned that we create all
these new organizations so we want
donuts so we have donut maker we want
bagels we have bagel maker we want bread
we have bread maker the end you have
this kitchen full of all these 501 C 3 s
that you're each paying ten thousand
dollars to to make donuts bagels
whatever rather than you know a bread
factory or something but the issue is
from a strategic point of view can you
see the money following into those
shared environments if you want shared
services money has to follow into shared
environments and those networks of
interaction and universities scholars
providers you know working for OCLC one
of the interesting things about the
whole innovation digital discussion is
it quite often doesn't include those
people upon whom you might rely to
deliver a variety of services that's a
very and here's a doughnut maker and we
built it ourselves here's a bagel maker
and we built it ourselves
this becomes important when you think
about what's happening you know more
generally so collective collection
mentioned a few times you just think of
our print shared print we're seeing this
sort of multi scalar a collaborative
environment emerge where libraries are
beginning to do things at a variety of
scales now this is natural enough as
things begin but then the coherence
question is how do we begin to sort out
where to actually invest time and energy
and do things and how do these things
begin to relate together do invest in in
all of all of these areas and if you
think about the range of things that we
do we have this multi scalar question
coming up in a variety of contexts
planning and strategy the Harvard
Business Review article that was
mentioned earlier quotes Henry Mintzberg
various of you will be familiar with
mintzberg he has this very nice idea of
emergent strategy so what he says is you
have deliberate strategy you know the
document comes down from the top this is
what we're going to do quite often that
becomes unrealized strategy because you
know you know we didn't quite get to it
this year but at the same time the
environment is changing things are
happening and you have an emergence
tragedy you have what you actually begin
to do in response to that changing
environment and the realized strategy
the strategy that actually happens is
some combination of emergent strategy
and deliberate strategy if you want to
influence emergent strategy will then
you come back to the importance of
vision so if an organization has a
vision if an organization has a clear
pattern of expectation if an
organization has a culture that is
oriented around particular values then
the emergent strategy will tend to flow
in in particular ways and and interact
positively with the deliberate stratagem
they'd be the quite nice statement in
the original article where they talked
about this is strategy formation walks
on two feet one deliberate and one
emergent the importance of emergent
strategy signals the importance of
culture vision shared patterns of
expectation
and that's because everything is
changing I put this picture in because
it just shows how things are changing
this is from University of Utrecht
showing a range of tools and services
that now emerged to help people with
scholarly work flow and have you have
you digested that
this is one part of a blown up a bit and
you know quite interesting you know goes
through looking at various things to at
the bottom are quite interesting the
range of Google tools but then also
digital science at the bottom you know
the range of tools being a you know I'm
symplectic read q biometrics digital
science very interesting company and
associated with big publisher obviously
but be interesting company and I'll skip
this and the interests of time although
it's quite subtle and quite interesting
so information policy I green it won't
say anything about some Patrick so you
know quite interesting in the in the
general discussion and going back to the
picture i just showed reputation
management big big focus on thinking
about assessment the organization and if
you look at publishing publishers
developing scholarly work flow so whole
range of activities here we focus on
open access as a an appropriate and
direction and focus but if you look at
how publishing is changing if you look
at how scholarly work flows are changing
if you look at how the way research is
done is changing if you look at the
emphasis on assessment ranking the
importance of publication in that the
importance of citation in that and you
think about you know what's going on
here one one thing to reflect which I'm
just surprised we don't hear more often
about isn't more maybe the Academy has
outsourced to some extent reputation
management to the publishing apparatus
and this is a huge issue and one that if
things are going to change in a
meaningful way that you know that then
has also to change but you know when you
look whole range of activity going on
there which is quite interesting I
thought there might be more discussion
about this concentration and diffusion
if you think about what's happening in
the network environment what's happening
is and much of our network life is
organized by large digital platforms and
aggregators
how many people in the room have ever
used Facebook how many people have ever
used google mail okay so even even warm
cuddly things you know the things we
think of as warm and cuddly and we know
might use them you know kick starter
etsy so what these basically or
organizations are large digital
platforms that create infrastructure
concentrate infrastructure and then you
have apps or you have at with that see
you have individual merchants with
Kickstarter you have individual
entrepreneurs so there's a concentration
and the diffusion the concentration
allows some creativity to flourish among
the entrepreneurs for kickstarter among
the merchants with etsy but they go hand
in hand they go hand in hand in a
library context we suffer we don't have
those large platforms we talk about them
we talk about interoperability we talk
but we only have a few and large
platforms they are important because
they are the sensors they are the
gateways sensors spelled Sen s ORS they
they they measure data they measure
traffic they know what's going on so a
whole set of very important issues
around this that wasn't really disgusts
our pants on and advocacy are very
important and thinking about the role of
the library in relation to creation so
the library really is an advocate for
creators are people who are creating
material and those creators need access
to materials to help them create so i
think that the role of the library
stepping out of the twilight whatever
the phrase was in terms of thinking
about their role supporting creation in
their campuses means supporting people
who want to use things to create and
advising giving and support to to to
creators so almost on time I finishing I
thought I'd put up my my well this is
the penultimate I thought I'd put up my
favorite quote about libraries
you know I had a slide already but the
the point is the library is a place has
no agenda other than allowing people to
have invent their own agendas I think is
particularly strong and it's a sort of
ironic statement because to do that you
need an agenda you have to have an
agenda to be able to have the ability
not to have an agenda other than to
support your user having an agenda if
you see or I mean so I think it's
actually even stronger than it appears
to be so I am going to finish with a
poem and there was a young librarian
named Jim who drank life to the very
brim from his base in Columbia he was
the scourge of kumbaya it's not easy not
retired his real influence will now
begin thank
thank you all this was a wonderful day
and enjoy the snow